people ask the question you know you
know is there wealth to be making people
become rich in the green economy well
frankly the only place people are going
to be able to get rich is going to be in
the green economy we are at the end of
an era of us capitalism was really in
you know inaugurated by Reagan
Reaganomics is over the verdict has been
rendered we wound up with an economy
that unfortunately was based on
consumption not production debt and not
smart savings credit and not creativity
environmental destruction and not
environmental restoration and as a
result we have this horrible meltdown
when we talk about the green economy
we're not just talking about some niche
economy that's good for you know the Eco
elite who can afford to pay a green
premium for a slightly more ecologically
friendly product that's not the green
economy we're talking about that's
important we like it but the green
economy has got to be more than just a
place for affluent people to spend money
it's got to be a place for ordinary
people to earn money and low-income
people to save money that is the that
will be the forward engine for this
economy we can repower the economy by
building a green collar economy where
people can have pathways out of poverty
not just green jobs with green careers
going you know from poverty to
prosperity maybe starting out installing
solar panels becoming a manager becoming
an owner becoming inventors and
investors entrepreneurs in this green
space led by the transition on energy
that's the only place we buddies don't
make any money the rest of the economy
is going to continue to go down down
down the gray economy is finished and it
may persist but in terms of its you know
a long downward tail but all the new
entrepreneurial opportunities all the
new economic opportunities are going to
be in the green and clean up